on revient à montréal que des
propriétaires soient excédés de voir des
itinérants coucher devant leur immeuble
ce problème urbain certainement réel un
problème social bien connu à montréal
mais de là à installer des pics comme
vous avez vu pour elle comme pour
éloigner les oiseaux
ça fait réagir aujourd'hui très
fortement françois quand le maire koné
rabri que ça existe à montréal disons
qu'il n'est pas très heureux
patrice lemaire coderre il s'est
présenté sur les lieux pour voir de visu
de quoi il s'agit c'est vous savez en ce
moment en grande bretagne l'installation
de ce genre depuis que pour empêcher les
itinérants de dormir devant des
commerces ou encore devant des immeubles
ça fait un grand débat le devoir
révélait ce matin qu'il y en avait à
montréal notamment devant ce magasin
faut préciser quand même que ce n'est
pas le magasin en question le qui les a
fait installer c'est le propriétaire de
l'immeuble et il semble que la colère du
maire a eu un effet instantané parce que
vous allez voir sur les prochains images
les pics ont été retirés en début
d'après midi
on nous dit que ça existe ailleurs à
montréal on en a vus nous à certains
endroits notamment sur précédé par
ailleurs le maire nous a fait savoir que
les gens commençaient à les retirer
tranquillement donc le maire qui était
sur les lieux je vous le disais on avait
une caméra sur place à ce moment-là on
peut l'écouter
s'il faut qu'on la rachoune ou même à
l'arraché nous mène dans ma ville c'est
pas vrai qu'on va avoir des volumes il y
ait des gens et ça c'est totalement
inacceptable a pas de place ici qu'on va
les faire enlever immédiatement loger
j'ai mon nom de l'acteur qui est là soit
sa part antonio
bon ben c'est clair c'est clair françois
vous êtes par ailleurs toujours sur la
rue sainte-catherine et le maire lance
ses consultations parce qu'il veut
penser moi l'expression mais revente et
l'amène complètement
oui c'est sainte catherine doit être
refaite au complet entre atwater et la
place des festivals alors la ville veut
savoir ce que vous aimeriez donc y voir
est ce que ce serait des trottoirs plus
larges ou encore une rue qui serait
complètement piétonne donc ce sont des
espèces de consultation oui mais pas
besoin d'envoyer un mémoire l'ayant site
internet où on peut envoyer des
suggestions
le maire prévient déjà que ce sera
difficile pour les commerçants ces
travaux là les commerçants sont quand
même un peu et clients on peut donc été
à nouveau le maire pas d'air mais aussi
directeur général de destination
centre-ville
moi je veux de la dass
mais je veux de l'inclusion on est une
ville de design on se dit une métropole
de design faites nous rêver
c'est certain que ça sera difficile à
chaque fois qu'une quelconque
perturbation c'est difficile mais y'a
lieu si on a des contributions
intéressantes et de l'écho de la part de
l'hôtel de ville de résumer ces
inconvénients la patrie ce sont des
travaux qui devraient commencer au
printemps 2016 on sait pas quand ils
seront terminés ni combien ça va coûter
parce qu'on sait pas exactement
évidemment à quoi ça va ressembler tous
on va mettre sur notre page de sites
internet il ya des gens qui ont des
idées et pourquoi pas allons-y merci un
françois au revoir pas très sympa